[Music]
at this point virtually nobody on earth
scratches their heads and wonders how is
it that wealthy actors tend to look so
fit and healthy
the answer is simple they have teams for
that and more often than not they're in
tip-top shape because they're being paid
to do so
when it's time to get absolutely
shredded for their latest action movie
actors assemble their fitness avengers
exercise coaches
nutritionists stunt men with years of
experience professional mixed martial
artists
and anyone else who might be able to
take an already in shape body to the
superhuman level
there are very few actors out there as
ripped as chris hemsworth is which makes
sense considering who he plays in the
marvel cinematic universe it's one thing
to be a super soldier like steve rogers
as far as i'm concerned that's america's
ass
or an intergalactic guardian like peter
quill but it's quite another to be thor
the asgardian god of thunder and
while thor was in a very different kind
of shape by avengers end game looking
rounder around the middle and longer in
the beard hemsworth in real life tends
to keep himself pretty jacked
strongest avenger access denied
strongest avenger access tonight
recently hemsworth decided to get into
the app business and create a center
a paid to use app that makes his team of
fitness professionals your team
too with customized meal plans and
workout regimens to help you reach your
health costs
and what better way to promote center
than to post a hilarious ad that blends
hemsworth's unfiltered aussie humor with
his dedication to fitness and his
personal team's expertise
allow my soothing baritones to wash over
you
i love you hemsworth took to instagram
on march 23rd to share the ad with his
47 million plus followers
it features a number of people working
out who all just so happen to be the
actor himself
sort of in the video hemsworth's head
appears over the bodies of a number of
people
most of whom are dedicating themselves
towards some kind of physical
or mental wellness working out doing
yoga meditating
and so on hemsworth speaks all the
dialogue discussing in very colorful
terms how unlikable he is and how
awesome the people who work with him are
in hemsworth's words he's a
dick and his team is brilliant two women
who again
both have hemsworth's face discussed how
they prefer chris's brother
luke for example and a guy cooking
things up on the grill confesses he'd
rip off chris hemsworth's face in a cage
match
those who have kept up with hemsworth's
personal and professional endeavors will
recognize this new clip as an uncensored
version
of a center ad that ran in february it's
the same premise
hemsworth's head superimposed over at
the people's bodies
him saying that working out with his
team is basically like working out with
him
but with updated dialogue not fit for
little ears it ends with the tag you
don't have to be chris to get results
you just need his team the point of that
is that whether you love or hate chris
hemsworth
something most of us can likely agree on
is that he clearly has an excellent team
keeping him in shape
that's where center comes in it's a
wellness program hemsworth curated that
includes a number of experts he's used
over the years to get into the kind of
shape required for the different roles
he's taken
boxers gold medal winning gymnasts yogis
chefs
and even podcasting therapists make up
the squad hemsworth is currently putting
the fruits of his fitness labels to use
to film thor love and thunder
the fourth solo film centered on the god
of thunder
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite workout routines are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one